>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[silence]
>> LUCIA WOLF: Good afternoon
and welcome, everybody.
And we are so glad to have you
here at the Library of Congress
for this unique opportunity
with Edoardo Albinati,
one of the most interesting
and original contemporary
Italian writers,
but intellectual in general.
But, I need to thank you,
Edoardo Albinati for being here,
accepting our invitation.
I know you have a lot of
appointments around town,
so making time for this
was very generous of you.
And I also want to
mention our co-sponsors
who made this event possible:
New Academia Publishing
and especially Dr. Anna
Lawton, and Italians in DC
and the book club ParoLab.
Finally, of course, I need to
mention the Italian Embassy
and the Italian Cultural Institute
who are also participating
in this event.
So. Excuse me.
I'm just going to get
organized a bit.
Let's start with a difficult
introduction of Edoardo Albinati
because your career is very
impressive and you are, I believe,
a Renaissance man we
could say in some ways.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I didn't
realize there was a Renaissance
in Italy, so if I am one of
these men, I'm very proud just
because it means that
there is a Renaissance.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Ah, okay.
Let's hope there is a
Renaissance and there was.
Dr. Albinati was born
in Rome in 1956.
He comes from a northern
Italian family.
His mother was from Piemonte
and the father's family
was from Lombardy in Italy.
That is the northern part of Italy.
He attended the private
school of San Leone Magno,
in the so called Quartiere
Africano di Roma.
It is called Quartiere Africano?
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
Quartiere Trieste.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Quartiere Trieste.
No need Quartiere Africano
in particulare.
Okay. The streets are named
after African countries
but Quartiere Trieste
is (inaudible).
Okay. He is here to celebrate
with us his award winning novel
for which he won the Premio
Strega in 2016, and we're talking
about his neighborhood
and his background
because that is a significant
part of his latest novel.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Yeah,
that is the best part
maybe of this neighborhood.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Oh Coppedè.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: yeah.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Quartiere Coppedè.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Realized
in a sort of late liberty style.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Very fun to wander
around that Quartiere Coppedè
and notice all the
various fountains.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Very good
as a set for horror movies.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Dario Argento.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
Yeah Dario Argento.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Certo.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Dario Argent
shot his first movies there.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Yeah.
So I want to do something
slightly different here.
We're not going to only
concentrate on his latest novel
because I'm happy to say that we
have almost every book written
by Edoardo in our collections
here at the library.
There are a couple missing
but maybe I can acquire them
in the next future.
So, I want to focus on your
overall career rather and talk
about also some other books, say
some Svenimenti, Sintassi Italiana
because I think that is as
interesting as your latest novel
for us here at the Library
of Congress and in America.
We were talking about
San Leone Magno,
the private catholic
school he attended.
You also attended Li Giulio
Cesare for the last period
of your high school years.
This is all very important,
we're touching upon it
because again Roma is so much
part of your works in general
and in particular, these
places, these locals are
so much important for
his latest novels.
They're almost the main characters
at time in the latest novel.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
Yeah, that's correct.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Giulio Cesare is
also a very particular high school
and it became iconic
in our culture, right?
Because there was an
assault, a terrorist assault,
at the Liceo Giulio
Cesare in the 1980s.
Rome at the time Edoardo was growing
up and frequenting these schools
and going to the Giulio
Cesare, that was later 1980,
was a very complicated
place to live in because
of all the terrorist attacks
but also the student movements,
and feminist movements, and
protests every day but mainly
because these were the
years in which Italy
and Rome saw this very tragic
phenomenon of the Anni di Piombo,
the so called Lead Years.
We will talk some more about that.
>> LUCIA WOLF: So, I am moving on.
We keep all these main bits in mind
because they're going to be part
of our conversion later
but Dr. Albinati graduated
from Rome's University La Sapienza,
which is also my alma mater
and with the thesis
supervised by Walter Pedullà
who was a very important, and
is still an Emeritus Professor
at the University of Rome.
The University of Rome
had some of the most,
the finest Italian literary minds
and historians of the 20th century
and so it was honestly a wonderful
place to study and work in,
in spite of the terrorist attacks
and what that might have created,
and the protests that
might have created some
fragmentary experiences.
So, as I was saying Albinati
is a Renaissance man,
in the sense that he isn't only
a novelist, he isn't only a poet
but you also translated
some important works,
English works into Italian.
Nabokov is one of them if
I recall and also Milton.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I
adapted Milton for the theater.
It was not really a translation.
It's impossible to translate.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Yes.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
I just cut and paste.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Okay.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Very freely.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Freely?
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Free.
[crosstalk] patient.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Well,
you have to with Milton.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: But
I liked that very much.
>> LUCIA WOLF: I love-
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I like very
much cutting, more than translating.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Okay.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
Cutting and translating that.
Adaptation is something a little
different from translation
but it's a good work for a writer.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Yes, learning the
inner dynamics of writing and ...
So we were saying, it would
take me a very long time
to mention all the various
not jobs but professions
that Dr. Albinati has been
doing- screenplay writer,
radio broadcaster, editor, literary
critic, novelist, essayist, poet,
and also a reporter, a
reportage in Afghanistan.
But one of the other main jobs,
I'm sorry, that Edoardo is known
for is he teaches in
Rome's prison Rebibbia.
It's a very important part
of your professional life
and I think you're
still doing that, right?
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Yeah.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Okay.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
That's actually the ...
All the other jobs I did them for
a while, this one is the only one
that I still do after 24 years.
>> LUCIA WOLF: And
you teach Italian?
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
Italian and history.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Okay.
Wonderful.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
But more Italian
because I don't know history very
well so I tend to, I prefer to focus
on language and literature.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Right.
One of the works we're going to
focus on Maggio Selvaggio is also
about your work at Rebibbia.
Since 1984 you collaborated also
with the literary journal
Nuovi Argomenti,
collaborated as an
editor, Redattore.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I think
I stopped in this year.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Okay.
All right.
Okay, so I have-
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
I quit in this year.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Okay.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I have a very
confused idea about my career.
>> LUCIA WOLF: That's-
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: As I told you,
when I saw the books over there,
I don't have many of
them so I'm happy-
>> LUCIA WOLF: Wonderful.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: -in
some place they're kept.
>> LUCIA WOLF: We'll do some
facts-checking, which is something
that we are all doing very often.
These are maybe real facts but we
need to look into this particular.
So, I mentioned Nuovi Argomenti
because it is also part
of our collection here
at the library.
I happen to find the first two
numbers of the Nuovi Argomenti,
which was founded in
1953 by Alberto Moravia
and Alberto Carrocci,
two very, very ...
two giants of Italian literature.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: That's why ...
I'm sorry.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Yes,
please interrupt me.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
Because I'm sure,
since Moravia died in 1990, I quit.
That's for sure.
>> LUCIA WOLF: So it's 1990.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
That's for sure.
>> LUCIA WOLF: By that
time, you had quit.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI : Yeah.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Your first novel
Il Polacco Lavatore Di Vetri,
the Polish windshield cleaner, was
published by Longanesi in 1989.
It provided material for a
movie, which was directed
by Peter Del Monte
and released in 1998.
We will talk more about
this novel but you went
on to write other novels, Svenimenti
published by Einaudi in 2004.
Tuttalpiù Muoio with Filippo
Timi, published by Fandango in 2006,
which we do not have yet
and I was telling you
that I would love to acquire it.
Dr. Albinati also wrote collections
of short stories starting
with his very first one is
Arabeschi Della Vita Morale,
another item that is not
yet in our collections
but we have almost everything.
Orti Di Guerra followed
in 1997 followed by 19,
which we also have
outside in our display.
Voci Nel Buio in 2005
by the publisher Charta.
We received 920 books, a donation
from Charta when they closed in 2014
and Giuseppe Liverani was
here for that occasion.
I noticed that in particular and
I think it's important to tie
in publishers, authors
and the milieu
of the whole situation and context.
Anyway, progressing with Dr.
Albinati's career as an intellectual
and a writer, he wrote another
short story collection Guerra
Alla Tristezza!
published in 2009, sorry I
was switching to Italian,
published in 2009 by Fandango again,
which seems to be one
of your main publishers.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: It's
100 meters from my house.
It's the main reason I
publish some of my books there.
>> LUCIA WOLF: That's great.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: It's
in the Quartiere Trieste.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Yes.
Practical.
But he also wrote poetry.
So we don't only have
prose but poetry.
Sintassi Italiana published in 2002.
He wrote autobiographic works
such as Maggio Selvaggio,
which we mentioned before, refers to
his work as a teacher in the prison
of Rebibbia, not to mention
his exceptional reportage
from Afghanistan, Il Ritorno:
Diario Di Una Missione
In Afghanistan published in 2002.
Now this doesn't do you justice but
I just needed a brief introduction
and we will move on to the
next phase of our event,
which is our conversation proper.
But, I love the fact that you
interrupted me and please continue
to do that because it will
flow more as a conversation
and help me relax a little bit more.
>> LUCIA WOLF: So, First of all,
a very brief personal question.
I'm very curious about this.
How did your family
happen to move to Rome,
to be in Rome, from Northern Italy?
I'm always curious about
people coming to Rome and-
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I must
confess that I don't know.
I never studied my family history
and my parents gave us short
information about their past.
I only know that my father
was the son of a builder
and Rome was a good place to work.
So there was a strong immigration
in Rome, not only from the South
as is usually thought,
but also from the North.
Many northerners came to Rome, this
town, Rome was I think 80,000 people
and it became the capital of Italy.
>> LUCIA WOLF: The
capital of Italy, yeah.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: To become
a metropole like it is now means
that they had to build
buildings and many ...
I think maybe 20% of the
population have immigrated in town.
>> LUCIA WOLF: From elsewhere.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: My
father was an engineer
so he wasn't not let's say a worker
but he made projects and made money
as well because it is
quite a typical character
of Rome, the builder.
The middle-
>> LUCIA WOLF: Upper-middle class.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
Upper-middle class in Rome,
the builders are very important.
Now they decline but especially
in the years, in the fifties
and sixties, some of them were
good and made a lot of money.
My father, not too much
but much more than me.
>> LUCIA WOLF: This is interesting
because Rome is again much part
of your work in general and it has
a very interesting history also
of being a capital, like
Washington D.C., with few people
who are really seven
generation Roman
or seven generation Washington D.C.
and so I just wanted
to remark on that.
You lived in Rome.
You were born in Rome, you
grew up in Rome and you lived
in Rome throughout your life
but you lived through one
of the most difficult
times in modern history,
the so called Lead
Years, Anni di Piombo.
Rome was an epicenter but the
Anni di Piombo affected all
of Italy-Milan, Turin, and so forth.
How did that period mark you
and what do you recall of it?
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Well,
this period has been called the
Lead Years by the press, by movies
but I would like to
correct this idea,
or this let's say "idée fixe",
saying that this period was
probably a period of lead and gold
at the same time so it was
not only a period of violence,
or the violence at the same time
produced good and bad things.
I was not really affected.
I was twenty- let's see,
I was twenty-something
when all this started to happen.
It was not the organized
terrorism, the real military groups
like [inaudible] from the
left or from the right.
I was more interested, and affected
and directly involved in the fact
that during this period
it was very easy to kill.
For small groups, you didn't need
to belong to strong organization,
revolutionary, you could just, as
I tell in my book, my last book,
you can just spend one afternoon
deciding with your schoolmates
who do you want to
kill the day after.
Taking from a list of
enemies, political enemies,
some of them quite casually
chosen, others like symbols,
other just like personally hate.
This world was the main issue.
The fact that death was so
easy to administer, to give
and sometimes to be given.
And this is something that happened
especially in these neighborhood,
that was apparently built just
to be a very safe and calm
and bourgeois neighborhood, like
it was built with the purpose
of nothing happening,
nothing except having ladies
with the small dogs around,
or people running and walking.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Because it's
near Villa Borghese also
so it's a very residential
part of town.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: It's a
residential place, quite neutral
and that's probably exactly
this fact, this neutrality
that attracted these forces.
It was like-
>> LUCIA WOLF: A haven?
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: -sometimes I
make comparison with the sport ring
or a sport field in which nothing
is there but everybody can happen
because that two different
teams, they fight there,
and it was quite impressive
because from 75
to 82 there were more people killed,
left and far wing militants,
policemen, judges-
>> LUCIA WOLF: Politicians.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
-politicians, girls in this place.
But the first great crime
was not a political one,
or maybe it was a political one but
was a sexual crime, the one that is
at the center of my book.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Yes, so I was
setting the stage also for violence
because violence as you say it was
ubiquitous, this sense of violence.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
That's why Dario Argento
in a way understood the
hidden quality of this place,
the subterranean violence
that was inside this building.
>> LUCIA WOLF: I don't
know if everybody knows
about the latest novel we are
talking about, La Scuola Cattolica,
so would you like to just introduce
because we were talking about 1975,
about this episode that is
at the center of your book.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Yeah, it's
not the main argument when we talk
about the book but it's actually
correct to say that it is the center
of the book, and it's the only
reason why I wrote this book instead
of another one.
The fact that in this
school, San Leone Magno,
some students one year older than me
in September 75, so the school was
over actually for us, we were out of
school, we were at the university,
or I mean starting with
the university, college,
they kidnapped two girls, they
brought these girls in a place close
to Rome to the sea, a very beautiful
but at the same time quite
scary place called Monte Circeo,
the mount of the ancient
magician Circe.
They abducted them, these two
girls, there and during two days
and a half orgy, they raped them,
killed them or to say better,
they killed just one
of these two girls
but they thought they
were killed both of them.
Then they put the two corpses
inside the car and went back to Rome
and left the car just under the
place in which one of them lived
and went to have an ice
cream during the night.
After a while, the girl who
survived started to make-
>> LUCIA WOLF: To knock on the -
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: -to knock on
and to make noise and
the police arrived.
They opened this ...
How do you call it?
>> LUCIA WOLF: The boot.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
The boot of the car
and they didn't understand
what was inside.
There is a very famous photograph
because for a strange chance there
was a photograph, not a police one.
>> LUCIA WOLF: I know, I wanted to
put it up there but, it's scary.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I think that
no kind of literature or words
or telling can compare
this photograph
in which the girl's still
alive, all covered with blood,
comes out the boot and
just in this moment,
the caraboneers understand
that the other strange-
>> LUCIA WOLF: Bungled
up in a blanket.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
-blanket is that girl.
Two of these killers
were taken just in ...
because they were buzzing
around as sometimes they say
that the murderers, they don't want
to leave the place in which ...
they want to be captured and
actually it is exactly what they did
because they were captured,
because they were found at three
in the night walking around.
The third one actually was
never arrested and after a long,
long chase around the world,
it has been discovered in 2005
that he's dead and he's buried
in Morocco under a false name,
under a false identity of,
how do you say a Legionario?
>> LUCIA WOLF: French legionary.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: But of the
Spanish branch of the Legion.
So apparently he's dead.
>> LUCIA WOLF: So I-
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I know
they were my schoolmates,
that's the only reason
why I wrote this book.
>> LUCIA WOLF: This is the clue
of the book but really as you say,
it's not the main focus
of your book, right?
Because the main focus is La Scuola
Cattolica, education in Italy,
masculinity models, sexual
education and so forth.
So the great part of
your book is the context.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
The context, right.
>> LUCIA WOLF: An investigation
of the context that led
to this murder, this crime.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I
don't know if it led-
>> LUCIA WOLF: Led, yes.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: -really led,
mechanically led to this crime
but as a writer I thought
that it was useless
and I could not add anything to the
things already written and known
if I write about the crime
but I could write something
about the families in which were
very similar to mine family,
the family of [inaudible], the same
school, the priests, our teachers,
the idea of male identity, this
was only-male school at that time.
After just five or six years
I left school it became ...
How do you say misto?
>> LUCIA WOLF: Co-ed.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Co-ed.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Yes.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Only because,
not because of any
ideological progress just
because to have more students
because the simple thing
of not having girls after a while
takes the school to the collapse.
So let's say that all the
things that were written
about this crime were written until
my book to mark the difference
between let's say, people like me,
or people like normal
people and the killers.
While I wrote about all we had in
common, all the similar things,
all the things we share,
I share with them.
I think there are two
different kinds of morality.
The very easy one is to
separate yourself from the evil
and this was the reaction especially
from the male part of the public.
They are monsters, we have nothing
to do with this kind of violence,
we condemn it, we don't want
to be in any way compared
or confused with the killers.
There is another level of morality,
more difficult to deal with that is
to discover and to analyze
and to tell what actually
we have in common with them.
What part of us is
contaminated by the same evil.
Also, because I think that a crime
like this one was really
contaminating, very contaminating.
All the quiet society of this
neighborhood, all the families,
all girls and boys and
parents were like ...
How do you say?
>> LUCIA WOLF: An enclave?
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Something
happened and it was impossible
to take the time back and
except to try to separate, to-
>> LUCIA WOLF: Refuse any-
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: -refuse
any discussion about that
because it's something
that cannot be faced.
I tried with my book to
face it in the easiest way.
The easiest way that is sincerity.
>> LUCIA WOLF: So it's
a responsibility.
You feel this as a
moral responsibility.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Usually I don't
like very much the use of moral
when you write but there is a moral
position in writing that is writing
without rhetoric, and without
indignation, without false passion,
without pretending to be
scandalized by what you are
because you are the scandal.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Right.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: So don't
be afraid to be a scandal.
While very often especially in
Italian literature, there is a sort
of self-absorbing position in
which the writer judge the reality
and like separating good from evil.
>> LUCIA WOLF: So.
Wow, already?
Oh well. Great.
I wanted to go back to your other
works because they are so much part
of your career but also they
depict another version of Rome
and Rome's life and your life in
Rome but time goes by so quickly.
So, at this point, let's just insert
something about your first novel
because it's another aspect of Rome.
We're talking about all this
mentality, this lifestyle
and customs in Rome especially
of a particular class, right?.
But Rome is also immigration, right?
You have demonstrated
an interest also.
It's like a civic and socially
engaged interest although you work
on it with some sort of flair
because Il Polacco Lavatore
di Vetri, your first one was
about Polish immigrants in
Rome and a very common vision
for any Roman stopping
at the traffic lights
and you would have these
Polish, but not only Polish-
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: At
that time, they were Polish.
>> LUCIA WOLF: -cleaning
your windshield, right?
But yours is like an ironic take on
this section of Rome's population
and immigration in
Rome at that time.
Tell us more about this
aspect also of this city.
Immigration at that time and
how it affected life in Rome
but also how is immigration
affecting Rome today?
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Well,
when I wrote the book,
the immigration was a
very, very thin phenomenon.
It was caused more by the
fact of having a Polish Pope.
So, at that time during the
crisis of the Eastern countries,
this was the first time we had
immigrants because you know
that Italy has been a country
of people who were going abroad
so we were the immigrants usually
for more than 60 or 70 years
from the beginning of the century
until the sixties or...It has
officially been declared finished,
the Italian immigration
abroad, in the seventies.
Exactly in the same years, the
process started to go the other way
around and the first ones to
arrive were the Polish people
and this was very, very strange for
the common image of the immigrant
who comes from the South of
the world, so he's darker,
so is the usual one,
the one who's happening,
people come from Africa
or from wherever.
In this case, we had these blond,
tall, sometimes very handsome man.
At the beginning there
were just men.
It was a very strange ...
I must confess, more than from the
civic, or political or ethic point
of view, I was astonished by
the estetico presence of these,
let's say angels, it's very easy
to start working with the fantasy
about his fact, being
carefully, being tall
and blond they were perfectly
matching the idea of,
especially in a Southern country
as Italy is, where blond is-
>> LUCIA WOLF: The perfection.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
-the perfection of light
or the pure or the good or whatever.
So I wrote a pure fiction novel
about them without knowing at all
that I was the first
one to deal with this,
that in few years it would
have become a real issue,
a real political issue not
because of Polish but because
of all other ethnic immigration.
Until now there is a European
problem, very, very heavy,
and Italy is just like there in
this position so it's the door
of all this while 90%
of the people arriving.
They don't want to stay in Italy,
they just want to cross Italy and is
at the same time easy and
very difficult for them.
That's the reason why.
I didn't imagine that
I was opening an era
because I was just
interested in this.
For the most, some
of these characters
in these novels are taken
straight from mythology.
So the very beautiful girl, Polish
girl, is like heroine all good.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Classical yeah.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Very
classical and I didn't think
to make a political statement
about something that was not
at the time a political issue.
>> LUCIA WOLF: I brought that
topic because it clashes also
with the type of picture you
painted, the Roman bourgeois
in Coppedè, in Quartiere
Trieste, this kind of enclosed type
of community that is shocked
by the murder you talked about
but also there are other parts of
Roman life and society at the time
that are probably shocking also
for people of the same background
and it was interesting that you
wrote about immigration way ahead
of time, way before the
problem really emerged.
I am sorry but the time is expiring
quickly and I would like you
to be able to also ask some
questions so I don't want to hog all
of the time we have left and I
don't know how much time we do.
Okay. So I am going to let
you ask whatever question,
allow you to ask any questions
and please feel free to ...
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Did you
personally know those students
who did the crime and did you ever
imagine they could do something
like that?
And did they get sentenced,
through the judgment?
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Yes I knew them
because I was in school with them
and furthermore, one of the
two, Angelo Izzo, had a brother,
a smaller brother who was in
my classroom so it was my age.
The killers were born one year
before me but I went very often
to the house of Angelo Izzo
to study with his brother,
being at that time the family
quite ...having a lot of children
of these middle-class families,
it was quite common to have
in these only-male school two or
three brothers of different age.
So yes, I knew them very well
and I felt they were bastards
but with this kind of ...
The way in which you're a bastard
in school, nothing more than this,
they punch in the face someone
or they broke the glasses of one
of my schoolmates, but
they did things ...
They were fascists-
>> LUCIA WOLF: Bullies.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: No, it was more
like a political color let's say
but they showed the way of being
fascists not in a political way
but more with arrogance, with ...
But I didn't know when the big
crime had happened that just
after the school they were
already being on trial for rape.
I didn't know that because leaving
the school I didn't follow their
stories and paths.
So, they were already in
judgment for the rape of one girl
and then they upgrade this area.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Progressed.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: They went on to
jail then, they were not in jail?
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: They
were in jail for a while
because they were released
on parole,
after a while there was a very
strong economical compensation
to the victim of the first rapes.
But, after that, they
were sentenced for life.
But in Italy, you are
sentenced to life
but usually we don't
do more than 30 years.
So the real reason why I wrote
the book is the fact that in 2005,
so exactly 30 years after the
first crime, one of them that was
on parole committed another crime.
He killed two women,
mother and her daughter.
The daughter, she was
like 14 years old.
It was not a sex crime.
He just strangled them
and buried them.
This was the reason I wrote the book
because if there wasn't this return
of flame, it was like the eternal
return of the blood of the crime,
that obliged me in a way to
reconsider the first story
because I didn't want
to write about that.
I've been called, I can't
call it really a vocation.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Yes.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
A calling, a vocation.
In 2005 and after one year of trying
to understand how to tell the story,
what to write about, I started.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: I'm really
curious about your activity,
also about your activity
as a teacher in prison.
You said that you teach
history and Italian.
The Italian language
or also the literature?
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Both.
Both. I have to teach
Italian to Italians.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Right, I
was going to ask since you spoke
about immigration, if your
students are all Italians or also
from other places, or countries.
It's a novel question I guess.
I'd like you to say more about what
the motivation of these inmates is
for studying especially literature.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Spend time.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: I can see
the reasons for history but also-
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I can
answer immediately, spend time.
Spend time.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Because it's a
way for them to engage in something.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: It's
a way of doing something.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: How
is that useful to them?
And why literature
than something else?
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I teach
in a school that has ...
The main aim of the school is ...
How do you say, informatic.
So I'm the teacher of Italian but
among the professors of Math or-
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER:
Computer science.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: -computers
or whatever, I'm the only one
who makes humanistic teaching.
But the main push for them is to
go out of the room, how do you say?
>> LUCIA WOLF: Do something useful-
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: To do
something, to spend time-
>> LUCIA WOLF: -purposeful.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: -to see people.
To see people who are not
guards, or who are not lawyers.
So we are the only-
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: They wouldn't
be interested in that otherwise.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I think
the main interest is a human one
and not really-
>> LUCIA WOLF: Intellectual.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
It's not intellectual.
It's not purely intellectual.
There are some of them
who are like young nerds.
Nerds are everywhere, also in jail.
But it's just one in 100 let's say.
It's an interesting place
for teaching because-
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: [inaudible]
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Who knows?
I don't know if they
studied in jail.
Studying in itself
is not a warranty.
It doesn't give you any insurance
against the fact that continuing,
keeping on your criminal
life or not, that's for sure.
I teach the son of a patriarch
to a Moroccan coke dealer.
I don't know if this is going
to change his life or as soon
as he will be released, he
will start again, selling
and buying the same stuff.
>> LUCIA WOLF: Comet Zero.
He'll not just imagine.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Zero
unfortunately is dead.
Zero is the boy I opened this
book with, it was a very,
very fat boy who died
of a dose just two years
after the book was written.
Also the fact of having this kind
of students that changes a lot,
are released, or die, or they
are moved to other prisons,
teaches you to be very focused on
having outcome almost immediate
from every single hours
you spend there.
You cannot make plans for
five years, for the future.
So the future doesn't exist
at all, there is only present.
This time, this one, the same
hour we are living now together
in this moment and
we have to squeeze
from this hour everything we can
because we don't know, I don't know,
now I live, for being
here I'm a liver,
I will be next Monday again there
and probably there will be
something changed among my men.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER:
[inaudible] this crime of Circeo.
You say many times that the press
was focused on the killers but not
on the ladies, we almost know
anything about them and especially
about the girl who survived,
we've lost her traces.
We know that she survived and
then we don't know anything else
about her.
I was wondering why you too don't
tell anything of the book on her?
As long as that would be
for a reader interested to,
not only to have an insight on the
killers but also on the victim.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
That's a good point.
It was made many times about this
book but I can write only ...
I didn't make any research about the
killers as well, I just knew them.
I just knew how they felt, how
they thought, how they lived
and I could use all my
imagination and fantasy
to make an intensification of
these things that I already knew.
I knew nothing about the
victims and I didn't want to.
And I didn't want to make a
book about let's say balanced,
sort of the killers and the victims.
So it's just about the killers.
It's just about men.
All the female characters are like-
>> LUCIA WOLF: In the background.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
Background or the up or down.
They are never in the center.
It's a quality or maybe a
failure of the book, I don't know
but I didn't want to
invent on victims.
Someone did in Italy, someone
wrote a really awful book
about the thought of the
victim or especially the one
who didn't survive, fantasizing
about what she felt
during the the [inaudible].
I felt it was out of my
reach so that's why ...
The school is only-male school
and this is only-male book.
There are sisters, mothers,
fiancées, women raped ...
But they're always like-
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER:
Secondary characters.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Yeah,
they could win the Oscar for-
>> LUCIA WOLF: Runner up.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: -how do I
say, supporting roles in this case.
The next book is even more balanced.
But this one- a very interesting
fact that happened is that many,
many women read the book because she
was interested in this male world.
So, it's quite strange that almost
nobody complained about the fact
that there were no, or such a
few parts for women in this book.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: Thank you
very much for this conversion.
A comment and a question.
As I hear you speak, you know,
there is two words that keep
on coming back to me,
that is individuality
and also the word, "roles."
You have a series of roles
in displaying who you are.
I'm curious, I noticed you
would comment on your place
because it's kind of like a garland.
You flourish here, and you
flourish in another area,
and in another area, and while-
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
I flourished in-
>> LUCIA WOLF: No no you don't.
You just flourished.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: I don't
want to say what is the world
of the writer and what
is your world?
But I'm curious as to how you see
yourself in this place and time.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: To be sincere,
to me the problem is just of energy,
it's just a physical problem.
The fact that I have to waste a lot
of energy around, scattering around,
that's why my career
is so contradictory
as a writer and also as a man.
I did many different
things just because I had
to spend myself somewhere,
somehow, in different directions.
Only in the end I hope will be sort
of design in this going around.
Also, this book is so different
one from the other will probably
at the end, I hope this
end will be not so soon,
but will form a shape,
a significant shape.
But the reality is that
I have to through myself
in something in which I'm lost.
Teaching in jail is my main fun
and my main hobby and it's absurd.
I know on Monday when I'll be
there, in this place that nobody
in the world would like to stay in,
I will ask myself again
what I'm doing here,
what the hell am I doing here?
And I will do.
So, writing is another way of
consuming, wasting yourself,
staying stupidly still at the table
or doing nothing actually
except playing with words,
from an ethical point of view I
think it's quite understandable.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: I have a
question about the character
that narrates [inaudible] because
obviously it's you, from some point
of view, he has your
experience from school, your job,
but sometimes it feels like it's
not, like it's fiction of course,
so the narration is unsupervised.
So I know I shouldn't ask this to
you, but to what point it's you?
And to what point it's not?
If you could tell me [inaudible]
leave it to me of course.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Well,
in a word that is not me.
That's very simple but this
voice is built to use a large,
huge chunks of my experience,
myself, but as a literary creature,
this narrator couldn't be exactly
like me because I needed to have ...
First it's a contrast with the
other let's say the co-protagonists,
the main character of the book
is my schoolmate Arbus so I had
to make Arbus, well Arbus was really
clever and I could not be so clever
as a character, so I
think I am more clever
than the narrator of the book.
>> AUDIENCE MEMBER: You
are certainly less stupid.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: I'm
not better but this ...
The problem is that I don't
know who I am so I cannot say
that it's exactly me or not.
I exaggerated some tendencies.
For instance, in the book for
instance I say that I always cry
and it's true, I cried
quite often, not always.
This character cries, is never
able to cope with reality, never.
I'm able 50/50, always.
It's what I call intensification.
I don't know if it's the word with
that sense or means [crosstalk]
>> LUCIA WOLF: Magnification.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: It's usually
what poetry do with reality
to make it deeper, stronger,
more touching, more something.
Then they're bigger than reality,
usually you say bigger than reality.
So, I think that in the
narrative way you need the same,
so you have to do things
bigger or weaker than reality.
Anyway, reality, you cannot use it
because you don't know what it is
and if you are linked forever
just to the reproduction
of reality, it's strangling-
>> LUCIA WOLF: Suffocating.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI:
-suffocating for writers.
I must tell you one thing
that surprised me a lot.
The real person who's behind
the character of Arbus
after I published the book,
reappeared after 30 years
or 40 years in my life,
he liked the book.
He liked the fact that I used him
as a sort of model for a character,
many things which were
completely invented,
and the part invented was quite
heavy for a real person to accept,
and he accepted it, he liked
it, he liked this joke,
this playing with personality, or
individuality, so he's a genius.
Even in the book, I tell you that
Arbus was a genius and I can,
I have to confirm that the real
Arbus is a genius because he's ready
to be used by the play
of life and literature.
So he's really an open-minded person
because he didn't defend himself,
say I didn't do that, I
didn't do that, and different.
The same thing I did
with me, I used myself,
I used my body and memory and soul.
I don't have any respect for
life I must tell you that.
I like life, I like the
way of transforming,
that's why I like mythology in
which you change, you're a girl
and you become a tree,
or things like this.
>> LUCIA WOLF: A goddess.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: You can become
an animal or my favorite character,
Teresi, you can be
both man and woman.
That's fantastic.
I would like very much
to have this privilege
but I'm confined in my body.
>> LUCIA WOLF: So we
would have needed three
or four hours for what
I had in mind.
I thought we had plenty more time.
One hour looks like a
lot of time but then
when you actually use
it, it's not enough.
I think we have to stop here also
take my friends the technicians
above who need to stop
and get going.
But, thank you very much and I hope
you all enjoyed this opportunity
and thank you for being here.
>> EDOARDO ALBINATI: Thank you.
[applause]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.